parts of the Midwest could be battling
one of the coldest veteran days ever on
Monday as another blast of arctic air is
set to move into the central and eastern
portions of the country by Sunday it may
be hard to notice as snow brushes are
already getting a workout clearing off
windshields that's in northern Michigan
plunging temperatures are also helping
to bring early November snow to the
mid-atlantic states roads were slick and
traveled treacherous in Erie
Pennsylvania overnight meteorologist
Jeff beard le is here with the story
about the cold and the rest of the
nation's weather Jeff good morning hey
good morning Dana you know I could do
this weather cast in five seconds move
to Florida get ready pack your bags and
move right now that's how cold it's
going to be this morning as we wake up
good morning everybody freezing
temperatures and below in New York City
record low temperature already this
morning at 28 this is just an appetizer
for what is going to be an Arctic plunge
of air that arrives Sunday night and
Monday the core of that on Sunday and
Monday will be in the Upper Midwest
watch what happens as we head into
Tuesday look at that wind in Texas down
to the Gulf Coast freezing temperatures
wind chills even worse than that pakore
on Tuesday located near Chicago and then
the whole thing moves towards the east
gets windy and cold up and down the
eastern seaboard how low will it go in
your city minneapolis 8 and remember
we're not factoring in the wind actual
temperature Indianapolis 15 Dallas 25
New Orleans maybe down to the freezing
mark when you factor in the winds look
at how cold it will feel in Chicago as
we head into Tuesday morning four below
Madison six below then we head towards
the East Coast Cooperstown no baseball
at the Baseball Hall of Fame on
Wednesday morning negative three and
snowfall bill will be some it's not
going to be a huge deal but a few inches
possible in some areas and maybe the
first flakes of the season in New York
and Boston on Tuesday guys that's the
key we are gonna get some snow likely
here Jeff yeah a few flakes maybe an
inch of snow but a Burlington Buffalo 6
to 12 inches get your skis out excellent
can't wait alright Geoff Garrod le thank
you very much